after a year in quarantine people seem  to forget how to behave out in the real  world especially on airplanes take a  look  sit down now you can't hold us  on the ground  yes we  yeah see see this is way too much  patience  just way too much pace you got to knock  him the [ __ ] out right there right there  you're already knocking yourself out  look at this look at this [ __ ] i see  this he got to die  you're not gonna do this next to me no  what i'm gonna do is take three two  people in the back and i don't know what  i'm saying man we finna come together  and get this [ __ ]  you're not gonna look at me and eat your  masks no  you know what you did over here growling  at the goddamn floor why they didn't  cuff him though that's that privilege  again they didn't cuff him by the way  they should have trusted me from the  beginning he had on jean shorts i ain't  never met anybody trustworthy in jean  shorts